à gauche du ciel il y avait la planète
shadoks
elle n'avait pas de formes spéciales ou
plutôt est le changer au milieu du ciel
il y avait la terre qui était ronde et
qui bougeait sur la terre il n'y avait
apparemment sur la planète jib il y
avait des animaux qui s'appelait jbe
voici un jbe lui de près en voici un
autre et quand il y avait trop de
lipides à côté
la planète pencher les jb glissé il y en
a deux qui tombait c'était très gênant
surtout pour les gilly sur la planète
shadoks
il y avait des shadoks de deux sortes
déjà dock avec des pieds en bas qui
vivait au dessus de la planète et des
shadoks avec des pieds au qui vivaient
de l'autre côté et qui servait à
soutenir la planète par en dessous
comme la planète j'adore changer de
forme il y avait des shadoks qui
tombaient c'était très gênant c'est tout
pour les shadoks les shadoks élégie be
en y ont donc assez au bout d'un certain
temps de vivre sur des planètes qui ne
marche pas bien alors ils décidèrent les
uns et les autres d'aller sur la terre
tous avaient l'air de mieux approcher